hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another q a
for march this video is sponsored by
keeps which means we will hear more from
them in the middle of the video instead
of letting youtube randomly select
an ad and just sort of put it in the
middle of a sentence but first
some questions for anyone wondering if
you would like to ask questions for next
month leave them in the comments of this
video that's generally how i always find
metal battle said
what the voice acting role in a game
slash show you want most
i don't really have anything like this
and the same thing kind of applies to
everything that i always said about
writing a video game before i started
working at santa monica studio
when people ask me questions like this
my answer is not like i want to work on
this game
it's usually a team that i want to work
with when it comes to voice acting i
don't know which teams would be
the best to work with but i i always
just want to work with a group of people
that i can learn from
and that i connect well with and that
are fun to work with rather than an
individual
role or anything and voice acting is
certainly not something i have those
aspirations for
i'm having a lot of fun doing cameo
stuff with uh
studios i like but i don't have grand
aspirations for it i will leave the
uh more important roles to people who
you know went to school for that thing
and have dedicated their lives to it
rather than just me
if there's studios that i would want to
voice act with just like based on really
liking a lot of people who work there i
would go
rare for sure gunfire games would be
really cool i mean i would definitely do
night school again after having done
after party um i just i
you know i just love those people in
general i would go with fulbright
i would go with uh it's cheating but
i guess valve just because of my
ex-campo santo friends who work that i
feel like would be really fun to work
with but
yeah it's generally more that kind of
thing it's people i want to work with
rather than things that i necessarily
want to work on if they weren't
with cool people with one exception i so
badly just want to be a trailer lady by
which i mean not
not a woman who lives in a trailer i
mean like the red dead redemption 2
voice lady so like if i were to read
your comment metal bat
and that voice it would be what the
voice acting role in a game
show you want most just let me do that
it's really fun in red dead redemption 2
i also really like doing robots and have
done like three so far
i would do more robots for sure i think
the thing that also looks a lot better
is the final product
is like people criticize me for my
cyberpunk performance but i actually
don't think
my performance was an issue my
performance is fine certainly a role
that i'm not equipped for because it was
supposed to be so hyper-emotional but i
think the actual issue people are seeing
is not
my voice if they were to close their
eyes and listen to it it's the mismatch
between
my voice and the character animations or
facial expressions of the character they
seem very very disconnected and that
happens in an open world game
or a game where you have that many npcs
uh because you can't just
individually match every single one up
but it does make the voice
actor look silly rather than the
character model because that's what
you're physically seeing i know this
happened a lot in ghost tsushima where
someone would say something really
urgent but they wouldn't move at all or
they would like seem injured but not
sound injured like they're definitely
inconsistencies there and i think
because of that i have more interest in
working in animation a little bit more
often to see kind of more about how that
process
works outside of games where the uh
animation is not necessarily tied to the
expression because that's something
that's just so disconnected that i have
ultimately no control over
ladies skits said greetings from
melbourne australia g'day mate
uh question is how does the fast food
compare in the us to australia is it all
a type to be would you bring any
particular chain back to australia if
you could
there's definitely a lot of chains that
i haven't tried yet what i will say is
they aren't joking about portion sizes
like the size of a medium fries in the
us is the size of a lodge in australia i
could not believe
the size of a large drink from
mcdonald's
it it's j how is it all so big it's
ridiculous
i really miss the australian um like
bakeries
just just meat pies and sausage rolls
man vanilla slices
i miss it all so much here i really love
the way they do mac and cheese
um there's this place called home room
in oakland that i really love but
basically like
mac and cheese in the u.s is something
you order from a restaurant not
something you heat up in a microwave
as you do in australia unless that's
developed but they have
good fast food mac and cheese here
i do think whataburger is absolutely
fantastic and that is my favorite
fast food burger chain that i would take
home if i could hell i would bring it to
california if i could
i am also a big fan of shake shack um is
it all it's hyped up to be frankly
australian mcdonald's is way better than
us mcdonald's for any
americans who are watching who don't
know like you can get like pineapples
and
halloumi and i don't know why i've just
run out of things to list when there are
two things it doesn't give you a great
example but you can get really
fancy meals at an australian mcdonald's
like on
you know how they serve things at those
wanky pretentious restaurants on like a
board with your fries in the basket they
do that at mcdonald's in australia it's
so much
fancier we have all these healthy wraps
that you can get
uh way less of that in the us australian
mcdonald's is better australian coffee
is better from even from mcdonald's
because then the cafe is just different
they make the coffee so much better
but uh yeah whataburger and shake shack
here
i know it's illegal to say it but i
think in and out
is overrated okay bye easy one two three
said nobody gives a [ __ ]
about what
about what jim wilson a lot of food
questions this time have you tried the
trader joe's fake tim tams not as good
as the original but pretty damn yummy
they also have them at um target and i
will say i think that this is
blasphemous
they offend me okay not to like go
full karen but the fact that you think
that that is a tim tam when it's like
not even made the same way
it's like really [ __ ] up okay
so no i don't i don't like them very
much i would take uh an entire carton of
australian tim tams versus the ones from
target
where i can eat like one and then i'm
just upset and homesick
it's a harsh review but it's true it's
time to talk about keeps which i like
talking about because there are a lot of
things people are insecure about and hey
no pressure and beautiful as you are but
if this is something you feel insecure
about well
did you know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
and the best way to prevent hair loss is
to do something about it while you still
have hair
left you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription but now thanks to keeps you
can visit a doctor online and get hair
loss medication delivered right
to your home not only does it make it
easy by delivering your medication every
three months it also cuts out those
awkward doctor visits one thing that i
think is really important that i always
like to bring up with keeps as well is
that they offer generic versions of the
only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there and that's probably a big part of
why keeps has more five star reviews
than
any of its competition and why hundreds
and thousands of men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication
which for the record i do have a couple
of personal friends who use the service
uh and really really like it but
generally keeps treatments take
typically between four to six months to
see results so it's important to act
fast the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you'll save
so if you want to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash alana pierce james dyke said aside
from deathly what games are you looking
forward to playing this year i'm running
out of things to play i'm definitely
looking forward to halo infinite
ratchet clank oh now i'm just blanking
on every game that's coming out this
year what
game releases 20
21 oh near replicant and pokemon snap
they come out like in the same week
that's gonna be a good week for me
returnal is also out just after that
resident evil village for sure i'm
loving
what resident evil has been doing lately
just so sad when you think about
silent hill fans of which i am also one
it's not not quite comparing what what
one of these
classic horror franchises is doing
versus the other one is
brutal to look at definitely looking
forward to key number to the spirits
which is coming out on my birthday
august 24th
and then there are a bunch of to be
announced games 12 minutes that looks
really good
elden ring obviously rumored but i don't
know if that'll come out this year that
doesn't seem likely to me ghostwater
tokyo for sure
psychonauts 2 i don't know i'm sure
there are a bunch that i'm forgetting i
just try to take them as they come you
know
my most anticipated game this year
really would be death loop though i am
such a fan of arcane
i think that that gameplay loop looks so
cool i'm really looking forward to
playing it brian pugo said hey lana any
thoughts on releasing any type of merch
shirt stickers etc um we have much
play watch listen the podcast so you can
check that out on redbubble all proceeds
go to charity
i have released one shirt and i did have
some merch on an old red bubble ages ago
that i never
pushed because it was all bad um but i'm
not really comfortable with much
because i don't see myself as
like a personality even if i am i don't
see myself that way me selling merch
feels weird
what other person who works at
playstation studios has their own merch
it just doesn't you know my whole career
because i've always been attached to a
company that is much much much bigger
than me it just
feels very odd it doesn't feel like the
right fit
but i will do it if it is for charity or
for some kind of good cause and i do
have something that i should be able to
announce
pretty soon that it's technically
outside of that that was just so cool
that when it was offered to me i didn't
want to say no
basically but i will announce that when
i can but generally not an avenue i'm
super interested in unless i feel like
it can be very helpful to someone
um i'm sure i will do more charity
collaboration stuff at some point going
forward but otherwise yeah check out the
play which listen match that is my only
real
consistent merch gram 909 asked uh do
you have a planned program of some kind
for your level up 20 21 wishing you best
of luck with it thank you so
um i've spoken to my physical therapist
and there's like very specific stuff and
i'm trying not to give too much detail
because i don't want anyone to just copy
what i'm doing directly um because i
don't know that that is the best for
other people they should all
get their own plans catered to their own
needs but i'm essentially doing uh
very very very lightweights a biceps
shoulders and back day and then
a pecs and triceps day uh i can't do
legs yet because
my knee is still too weak so there'll be
abs and some cardio in there as well
but it's all pretty limited for me right
now just trying to make sure that i
sweat for 30 minutes a day that's it
that's that's the goal
it is it is a bit more structured than
that but that is the main thing and i
did have a few people who uh have been
sharing this stuff with me
mention ring fit so i bought ring fit a
few months ago but
never actually ended up trying it it's
still sitting on my just under my tv
so i might actually give ring fit a shot
and um report back and let people know
how that is
becky hey check ck said when you first
started your youtube channel did you
have any anxiety or worries
no like maybe that people wouldn't watch
all your videos
or did you just never care about any of
that no i never cared about any of that
at all because my youtube channel was
just an avenue for me to get better at
speaking on camera and to learn to edit
videos so
i was never worried about growth or
people watching stuff or anything like
that because it was really more for me
um and then i ended up building this
really cool community and i do really
like talking to people and just trying
to be
positive about video games on youtube
even when speaking about them in an
editorial capacity because i feel like
a lot of the very popular channels are
really negative so that definitely
keeps me going for sure but um no i was
never worried about anything because i
never had any goals with it and i still
don't i'm not out here trying to get
subscribers or
trying to make a ton of money and that
is a tremendous privilege that i have
that you know i
have a entire career that i love and
then i also get to have this youtube
channel
that i have a really good time with but
um i think that that's also probably
part of what fed into
this being in any way tiny bit
successful is that i didn't
try to i was always just myself and
always have been just myself so
i feel like that helped out in the long
run res novkos will you continue the
streaming of deadly premonition too
i do plan to continue streaming deadly
premonition 2 now that i'm partnered on
twitch
um that was a thing that i just felt
weird doing on youtube because i was
like well i have all this content and
then i just have this game that most
people don't care about that i'm just
like
also throwing up on this channel and
it's so weird and it doesn't make sense
if you've not seen all the others
twitch being a platform that is just for
live streaming kind of takes me
away from that like organizational
producer mindset that really grew into
me at ign
of like well this gets published at this
time does this with this content how
does this go in this piece of this thing
that also like definitely you know
played into my role at funhouse as well
um and inside gaming there too
but now that it's just on twitch yes i'm
going to continue
streaming deadly premonition too and i'm
very excited about it those streams have
been
so much fun even bloodcloth said
question for next month how do you feel
about ign and and gamespot staff making
unprofessional and slanderous remarks
wow against someone when they point out
a certain review is half-baked cyberpunk
2077 review when she didn't actually
play most of the game
i think the person you're referring to
uh just blatantly lied about her they
said she didn't even finish it
um i think actually they might have said
she didn't even play it i think that is
what they said she didn't even play it
which is absolutely false they are
almost as much of a journalist as any of
these people who work for ignore
gamespot and should be held accountable
when they
just completely lie about someone to get
more views
um from an angry audience which is
exactly what they try to do
so and i don't know why it like seems
okay to people when
youtubers lie just because they're on
youtube like your favorite youtube
personality lying
can be just as harmful if not more than
someone at ign lying because you can get
a ton of [ __ ] views on youtube
and taught us what three books you as a
professional writer would recommend as
most useful to
aspiring writers i would very genuinely
say whichever ones inspire you the most
i think there isn't a key to writing and
everyone does it differently but i think
that
whatever book you're reading that really
like inspires you creatively or that you
feel like a lot of the words on the page
are written in a nice way or that
there's character development that you
really like um it would just be that so
really just reading a lot is my
recommendation
finding things you really like and then
taking the time to really think about
why you like those things um what about
the writing you liked what about the
characters you liked what about the plot
that you liked what about the pacing you
liked and then
finding ways to apply that to your own
writing is more helpful than like
telling everyone to read the same three
things it's just reading a lot
and knowing why you like what you like
so you can use that
feedback kind of on yourself alrighty
you guys that is it for me today
everyone i will leave a link in the
description below to where you can check
out more
from keeps but otherwise i will see you
guys next month bye